können wir eigentlich super helden
werden so wie bei den avengers iron man
captain america hulk usw bioventures age
auf alten startet jetzt im kino
und da ist die große frage können die
gene und übernatürliche fähigkeiten
verleihen
das erfahrt ihr jetzt bei pixum science
fiction forscher haben es bereits
bewiesen
gene können an und auch ausgeschaltet
werden erfolgreich angewendet wurde das
in einem versuch mit mäusen deren
muskeln durch gezielte steuerung von
gehen viel schneller gewachsen sind sie
wurden quasi durch genmanipulation zu
superhelden eine verblüffend einfache
entdeckung machte dafür
der molekularbiologe genie von der john
hopkins university in baltimore
er fand heraus dass mäuse denen das
eiweiß - takt ihm fehlt mehr muskeln
aufbauen haben sie dann noch mehr von
dem eiweiss police taten beten sie noch
mehr muskeln
er konnte so mäuse züchten die vier mal
mehr muskeln als ihre artgenossen hatten
und die doppelte leistung brachten
und es gibt auch menschen die diese
superkräfte haben ein mutierter
deutscher jugendlicher also dessen gene
sich verändert haben hat genau die
gleichen eigenschaften wie die mäuse ihm
fehlt das eiweiß - statt ihn im alter
von viereinhalb jahren konnte der junge
drei kilo gewicht mit waagerecht
ausgestreckten arm halten also das kann
mancher erwachsene nicht quasi ein
superheld bereit für die avengers
der molekularbiologe sebastian alfredo
von der stanford university hat sich
genauer mit den superhelden beschäftigt
und sich gefragt ob zum beispiel die
geschichte von captain america so auch
in der realität ablaufen könnte und
seine antwort ist ja
in der geschichte bekommt steve rogers
ein super soldaten serum initiiert und
im anschluss wird er mit vita strahlung
geschossen so heißt das da das absolut
verblüffende genauso wird heute im
prinzip in der medizin schon gearbeitet
gegen hauterkrankungen wie krebs oder
schuppenflechte wird von den patienten
der wirkstoff zur allen eingenommen und
nach einigen stunden werden sie mit
uv-licht bestrahlt diese bestrahlung
aktiviert das tor darin dass sich an die
dna heftet und das zellwachstum
verlangsamt genauso wäre das nun auch
mit veränderungen der dna möglich die zu
superkräften führen würden alvarado
schaute sich auch die geschichte von
hulk ein stück genauer an
die fähigkeit sich von mensch zu halt
transformieren zu können hat halt durch
einen unfall bei dem er mit heftiger
gammastrahlung bombardiert wurde
erhalten bei uns menschen also nicht im
marvel-universum passiert bei der
gammastrahlung folgendes chromosomen
werden sozusagen zerstückelt durch die
gammastrahlung kleine stücke werden aus
der doppelhelix unserer dna heraus
gebrochen der menschliche organismus
aber kann diese zum teil wieder in den
ursprungszustand zurückversetzen
rayo vermutet nun dass durch die heftige
bestrahlung bei hulk etwas
schiefgelaufen ist und die dna nach dem
unfall wieder falsch zusammengebaut
wurde warum halb grün ist erklärt sich
der mikrobiologe verhältnismäßig einfach
bei der verwandlung werden die roten
blutkörperchen zerdrückt das ist dann
wie bei einem bluterguss der sich nach
und nach ja auch grünlich färbt es ist
also schon spannend dass der fantasie in
der realität offenbar kaum grenzen
gesetzt sind und zahlreiche
fantastereien tatsächlich im rahmen des
möglichen liegen
und es gibt noch einen echten
superhelden unter uns menschen die jetzt
neunjährige leonard aus stockholm es als
einer geboren worden dafür
verantwortlich ist wohl eingehen dass
sich nur leicht von dem eines normalen
menschen mit schmerzempfinden
unterscheidet aber große auswirkungen
hat leonard spürt keinen absolut keinen
schmerz und leonhard ist nicht der
einzige mensch der kein schmerzempfinden
hat tatsächlich gibt es viele die mit
dieser genveränderung leben müssen ja
müssen denn vielleicht würden einige von
euch sagen super keine kopfschmerzen
kanals schmerzen keine schmerzen im
blauen flecken und so weiter und so fort
einfach keine schmerzen mehr
das wäre doch toll oder oder etwa nicht
in seiner kindheit wurde diese
superhelden eigenschaft leonard zum
verhängnis die folgen aus seiner
schmerzfreien kindheit
ja die sind verheerend mit den ersten 10
c bis er seine lippen nachts und
unbeobachtet group sich leonard
teilweise selbst wunden tief in die haut
und wenn er dann mal wieder im
krankenhaus war tollte erfreulich mit
einem oberschenkelbruch auf der
kinderstation herum er spürt einfach
keinen schmerz die forschung auf diesem
gebiet ist leider noch nicht sehr weit
für forscher ist der kleine junge immer
noch ein großes rätsel man darf
grundsätzlich dabei nicht vergessen dass
viele superhelden eigenschaften mit
erheblichen nachteilen verbunden sind
so werden zum beispiel die knochen von
menschen die besonders stark sind auch
besonders stark beansprucht und
verschleißen
dementsprechend früh erkennt man von
bodybuildern es wird also noch etwas
dauern bis wir wirklich super helden
werden können ob es sich lohnt die
helden über die wir eben gesprochen
haben im kino anzusehen das erfahrt ihr
aber schon jetzt hier in dem video bei
der filmfabrik und er konnte noch mehr
direkt erfahren und zwar wie es
beispielsweise aussehen könnte wenn ein
so ein superheld mal beim psychiater auf
der couch landet das seht ihr hier im
video von alexei vecsey und was haltet
ihr von superhelden wird er gern einer
und wenn ja welcher diskutiertes in den
kommentaren bis dann bleibt dran sagte
hancock der wäre ich glaube ich ganz
gerne nicht ganz so perfekt